we begin with breaking news former NFL
star Aaron Hernandez committed suicide
overnight in a Massachusetts prison
prison officials say the former New
England Patriots tight end was found in
his cell and pronounced dead at a
hospital Hernandez had just been
acquitted Friday in a 2012 double
killing he was already serving a life
sentence for a murder in 2013 Tony de
copal is here with this breaking story
Tony good morning good morning the
former New England Patriots star was
found hanging in his cell shortly after
3:00 a.m. this morning according to a
statement from the Massachusetts
Department of Corrections officers who
found him tried life-saving techniques
and he was transported to a nearby
hospital where he was pronounced dead an
hour later they say the 27 year-old
Hernandez hanged himself using a
bedsheet he attached to his cell window
he attempted to block the door with a
number of items in his room the police
are still investigating his death comes
just five days after he was acquitted of
murdering two men in Boston in 2012
Hernandez
his family has been notified now
Hernandez was serving a life sentence
without parole for the murder of Odin
Lloyd in 2013 Gael all right thank you
very much Tony